Ciao maryners e benvenuti in un nuovissimo
videooo, ops
Prima di iniziare volevo farvi vedere al volo cosa mi ha inviato pringles. la apriamo insieme? vediamo un po
No vabbè
ma è una porta da calcio
Portatile io adoro se volete anche voi dovete semplicemente seguire tre step step numero
1 acquistare tre tubi di pringle aderente all'iniziativa proprio come questo qui
Step numero 2 andare. Sul sito che vi lascio in descrizione numero 3 e seguire le istruzioni e partecipare proprio come me al pringles
training
Passiamo al nostro video oggi parliamo di mamme in particolare di quelle cose che fanno sempre le mamme. Buona visione
Carmelo stai esagerando io non te lo dico più, adesso chiamo l'uomo nero se non la smetti. L'hai voluto tu.
Uomo nero, c'è un bambino cattivo che non si sa comportare. Me lo vieni a prendere per favore?
va bene. Ha detto che arriva subito
Guarda che I piatti non si Lavano da soli e lo sai vero
Questa casa non è un hotel e non è un hotel, non puoi fare. Quello che vuoi
Hai fame eh mamma ma hai mangiato hai fame si o no che ti vado a cucinare qualcosa amore se hai fame dimmelo
gianni
ti ho detto di smetterla una volta per tutte!
Sant'Antonio aiutami tu per favore. Io non ne posso più, questa famiglia mi tratta come se fossi una schiava.
fammi una grazia almeno tu. Mandami un aiuto, un aiutino
Ho faticato tanto nella vita per avere una famiglia
e questo il risultato
Cosa ti costava avvisarmi? un messaggino bastava
Io non sono vostra madre, mi trattate come una serva. Lavo, stiro, pulisco ma a me nessuno mi vuole bene
guarda, tosa, togliti subito quelle scarpe che ho spazzato tutto il giorno
Vieni subito a mangiare che si raffredda cio, accendimi un attimo
La televisione che devo vedere il segreto che sta iniziando e non me lo voglio perdere accendi subito la tv!
amore di mamma, ma se ti porto una bella porzione di parmigiana sei felice?
Ti porto anche un bel cannolo ripieno sul momento, anche la pasta con le sarde, che problema c'è?
Smettila di piagnucolare, ricordati che se ti sgrido lo faccio solo per il tuo bene.
Carmine amore mio, forse non ci siamo capiti
Tu adesso stai zitto e mi rispondi
Adesso vai subito subito a fare i compiti e mi aiuti pure. Che problema c'è, ce qualche problema a fare tutte e due?
carmelo, io contro fino a tre.
se non fili subito a mettere in ordine la camera, ti sequestro il telefono e non  esci più di casa!
3 2 1.. L'hai voluto tu!
Tutto il giorno attaccato al telefonino sempre con hufhh lì,come se chiamano? musically
Di quella roba la quella roba lì demonio fin dai
Vediamo di fare un po di pulizia che ci abbiamo troppe robe la casa sommersa
Non mi piace, buttare. Questo già non mi piace questo lo diamo ai bisognosi. Basta, troppi vestiti, via tutto via via via via via
Guarda che cadi non ti dondolare più su quella sedia
Guarda che te lo dico che stai cadendo eh
te l'avevo detto
allora, forse non ci siamo capiti che
Prima o poi scappo, non mi troverete più
Me ne vado in Africa, vado dai bisognosi
Voglio vedere cosa fate senza di me. Senza una madre che vi ama, vi pulisce e vi lava i vestiti ah
Certo perché le magliette c'hanno le gambe vero che spariscono? Guarda che se te la trovo quella maglietta, scommettiamo che te la trovo?
Guarda cosa che ti avevo detto? Era proprio nel cassetto che ti dicevo io. Non trovi mai niente te!
Salvoooo, comprasti l'acqua?
meh, na cosa t'ho chiesto! tutto il giorno che stiro, veramente non posso fare affidamento su nessuno. Non ci sono parole proprio.
Amore di mamma hai qualcosa da lavare? Ho proprio voglia di fare una lavatrice dammi qualcosa
Dai, la maglietta l'hai messa già due ore, già puzza. Dammi dai. I calzini subito, subito i calzini veloce. Anche le mutande, che fai? Mica ti vergogni
Carmelo, sta andando benissimo a scuola
Si adesso sta facendo i compiti
Si te lo passo subito non vede l'ora di parlarti è da un ora che me lo chiede te lo passo te lo passo subito
Purtroppo siamo arrivati alla fine del video fatemi sapere, se vi è piaciuto ma soprattutto fatemi sapere
Lasciando un commentino qui sotto se anche voi almeno una volta nella vita avete detto una di queste frasi
Se non avete ancora fatto ricordatevi
Iscrivervi al mio canale e attivare la campanella che trovate vicino al tasto d'iscrizione per rimanere sempre aggiornati, su tutti i
Miei video e soprattutto essere i primi a commentare
Ricordatevi inoltre di seguirmi su tutti gli altri social facebook musically e instagram. Io vi mando un bacione ci vediamo al prossimo video. Ciao